J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, aujourd'hui, on aborde un sujet complexe et crucial, mais aussi très sensible : la couverture médiatique du conflit israélo-palestinien de ces douze derniers mois, puisque ça fait à peu près un an
depuis les attentats du 7 octobre en Israël.
Pour aborder cette question, je le disais, très sensible, j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir Marie Peltier, que j'avais déjà reçue il y a quatre ans avec Florence Hainaut.
C'était pour parler surtout de harcèlement. Marie Peltier est historienne, experte en médias et en construction de récits.
On va la présenter dans un instant. Je le disais, un sujet sensible. On a pu parler de beaucoup de sujets sensibles dans Septante Minutes Avec, les questions d'oppression, de racisme, questions de genre, etc.
Bon, celui-ci, c'est sans doute le sujet le plus compliqué, le plus polarisant, le plus divisant. On va entendre les opinions de Marie et les miennes, mais comme je le disais, l'essentiel de la discussion
va se concentrer sur la couverture médiatique. Donc
comment est-ce qu'on en a parlé
dans les médias en Belgique, aux États-Unis, mais aussi en France ? Comment est-ce que les différentes cultures
se positionnent vis-à-vis des questions coloniales, vis-à-vis des attentats, vis-à-vis des questions liées à l'antisémitisme ?
On a pu, voilà, faire un petit peu le tour du paysage sur toutes ces questions. Évidemment, comme je le disais, Marie a ses opinions, j'ai les miennes.
Vous allez entendre qu'elle se positionne sur plusieurs acteurs politiques et médiatiques. Et on termine cet épisode malgré tout, en quittant un petit peu les sphères médiatico-politiques et en repartant un petit peu du constat.
Voilà, Marie est historienne, je le disais. Donc, est-ce qu'il y a un apartheid en Israël ? Est-ce qu'il y a un génocide ?
Toutes ces questions, voilà, qu'on va aborder ensemble, puisque Marie est hautement qualifiée pour parler de ça.
Je précise aussi qu'on a enregistré cet épisode il y a déjà quelques semaines, ce qui signifie que la situation avec l'Iran, la situation au Liban et de manière générale, la situation géopolitique globale au Proche-Orient
n'est pas reflétée dans notre entretien.
Et voilà, comme vous le savez, la situation continue à évoluer au jour le jour. Au moment où je publie cet entretien, donc c'est, vous allez voir, absent de notre discussion qui se concentre plutôt sur les douze derniers mois de manière générale.
On décortique, comme je le disais, les dynamiques de représentation de ce conflit dans les médias, dans les sphères politiques, les biais potentiels, l'impact de cette couverture sur la perception publique,
la question des puits idéologiques, etc.
Bref, vous allez voir, préparez-vous pour une conversation très riche et nuancée. Et comme vous le savez, depuis cette saison, les épisodes de Septante Minutes Avec sont également disponibles en vidéo sur YouTube.
Je vous mets le lien en description. Bonne écoute. Mais j'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir de retrouver Marie Peltier. Salut Marie.
Salut.
Marie, on s'était croisés, on avait fait un podcast ensemble il y a déjà quatre ans avec Florence. On avait parlé de complotisme, de cyberharcèlement.
On avait un petit peu recroisé tout ça. On n'avait pas cité les gens, mais les gens avaient compris de qui on parlait, je pense.
Ah oui, je me rappelle.
Et on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour parler non pas de cyberharcèlement spécifiquement, même si je pense qu'on peut-- il y a quelques exemples,
mais sur un de tes domaines de prédilection, à savoir la construction de récits, et couverture médiatique
qui peut contribuer à ça.
Tu es donc, pour rappel, pour celles et ceux qui ne te connaissent pas, une historienne et essayiste belge spécialisée dans l'étude des théories du complot et des discours de propagande.
Tes recherches se concentrent surtout sur la désinformation, dans le contexte des conflits internationaux, notamment la guerre en Syrie.
On a eu l'occasion d'en parler un petit peu ensemble. Et donc l'impact des théories conspirationnistes sur tout ça et sur les sociétés démocratiques occidentales.
Et donc aujourd'hui, on va surtout parler de la construction de récits médiatiques puisqu'on va revenir sur un an de couverture médiatique depuis les attentats du 7 octobre, en Israël.
Donc ça fait, oui, ça fait presque un an. Donc cet épisode sort, je crois, juste après ou juste avant l'anniversaire.
J'ai un petit peu perdu mes marques en termes de calendrier. Mais voilà. Donc est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer un petit peu en quoi tu as pu travailler là-dessus, sur ces dernières années ?
Est-ce que c'est un sujet en particulier qui t'a animée ?
Ouais, en fait, il y a beaucoup d'aspects qui m'ont mobilisée ces dernières années parce que j'ai pas mal travaillé sur la question de l'antisémitisme aussi et avant toute chose.
Fin des années 2000, début des années 2010, je travaillais sur la question de l'antisémitisme. Je travaillais dans le secteur de l'éducation permanente, mais je m'étais vraiment spécialisée sur la question de l'antisémitisme.
Et forcément, quand on touche à la question de l'antisémitisme, la question du conflit israélo-palestinien est en ligne de fond, en ligne de mire en quelque sorte.
Et puis, j'ai tout mon travail plutôt sur le Moyen-Orient, sur les récits de propagande, sur la manière dont on raconte les choses qui se passent au Moyen-Orient.
Et donc, il y a un peu une,
un entrecroisement pour moi dans Israël-Palestine sur les questions à la fois d'islamophobie et antisémitisme,
et puis, les questions de récits, de propagande et d'identification au conflit,
puisqu'en Israël-Palestine, on a quelque chose d'assez particulier, puisqu'on a à la fois, comme fantôme du conflit, l'histoire de la colonisation, et on a aussi l'autre fantôme qui est celui du génocide juif, bien évidemment.
Et donc on a un écran de projection qui est particulièrement fort.
Un écran de projection sur lequel on peut rajouter des biais et quelque chose de très partisan. C'est très polarisant comme conflit.
Et donc, par exemple, ici à Bruxelles, on peut, selon les quartiers, mais on peut régulièrement voir des drapeaux de soutien à la Palestine, des gens qui ne jurent que par ça, qui sont très animés par le sujet.
Donc c'est très polarisant. Qu'est-ce qui fait que d'après toi, c'est autant polarisant ce conflit en particulier ?
Tous les conflits ne nous mobilisent pas tous de la même manière, c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas la charge affective, y a pas une même charge affective pour tous les conflits.
On peut évidemment directement donner la comparaison avec la Syrie, par exemple, où quand on essaie de mobiliser les gens pour la Syrie,
je le dis toujours, je radote un peu avec ça, mais c'est la vérité, on était quinze aux manifs quoi.
C'est-à-dire que, voilà, il y avait impossibilité un peu en quelque sorte d'identification de l'opinion publique à ce qui se passait là-bas.
Pour Israël-Palestine, en effet, on a un peu l'impression que c'est l'inverse. Alors, je pense que l'explication, elle est multiple.
Il y a évidemment le fait que Israël-Palestine, c'est un territoire extrêmement particulier lié à l'histoire des trois grands monothéismes.
Donc quelque part, tout le monde a un peu des racines en partie fantasmées, mais dans ce pays ou dans cette région.
Il y a aussi évidemment l'histoire de l'État d'Israël, le fait que la création de l'État d'Israël a suivi directement, en tout cas, le génocide juif, évidemment, commis en Europe, rappelons-le.
Enfin, rappelons-le parce qu'il faut le mettre sur la table. C'est quand même les Européens qui ont commis ce génocide.
C'est mieux de pas l'oublier.
C'est ça. Il y a aussi bien évidemment, en ligne de fond, en quelque sorte, l'histoire de la colonisation, puisqu'en fait, l'État d'Israël, ça rime au projet colonial, mais le projet colonial est un projet aussi européen à la base.
Rappelons que l'Europe, elle a colonisé à peu près le monde entier
et qu'à partir du moment, en quelque sorte, où elle a commencé un peu à se désengager, à quitter les territoires coloniaux, eh bien, il y a eu ce mouvement un petit peu anti-historique de colonisation au niveau d'Israël.
Quand je dis anti-historique, c'est pas... 'fin, c'est pas pour porter un jugement de valeur, mais c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu un mouvement un petit peu inverse quoi. En même temps-
Un petit peu anachronique dans le sens où à l'heure où on décolonisait un petit peu partout dans le monde, on a eu droit à une colonisation dans l'histoire récente.
C'est ça. Il y a en tout cas, ça arrive en tout cas à la fin de l'histoire de la colonisation. On pourrait dire ça comme ça.
Et encore une fois, quand je le dis ici en posant juste le fait et je pense que ça explique en partie l'affect qu'il y a, parce qu'aujourd'hui, il y a une grosse résurgence de la mémoire
de la colonisation, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une très grande demande d'un récit sur la mémoire coloniale.
Récit qui est pour le moment vraiment pas du tout au point. Pensons notamment à la Belgique avec la colonisation du Congo, etc.
On a encore beaucoup de retard pour reconnaître ce qui s'est passé. Donc Israël, je pense, 'fin, fait aussi les frais de ça, c'est-à-dire de notre rapport à la colonisation qui est pas encore très apaisé, c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Et donc comme là-bas, on a l'histoire d'un pays qui a une dimension coloniale, on peut pas résumer Israël à la dimension coloniale, mais il y a une dimension coloniale en tout cas.
Eh bien, ça vient, en quelque sorte... Moi, alors ça, c'est un peu mon opinion, je vais la donner, mais j'ai l'impression que les Européens aiment accuser les Israéliens de tout ce que eux-mêmes ont fait pendant des siècles.
Et quelque part, maintenant, on dit : « Ah ben vous voyez, c'est eux les méchants, c'est eux les méchants. » Alors que, ben d'une part, si je prends l'exemple de la colonisation, c'est quand même nous les maîtres, c'est très clairement.
Et puis deuxièmement, n'oublions pas que l'histoire du peuple juif est quand même un petit peu différente des histoires des Européens blancs et que donc il y a--
on peut pas tout à fait dire : « Les Juifs sont les oppresseurs » sans faire quelque chose de révisionniste quoi.
Sans vraiment la lecture d'une historienne, puisque tu parles donc de l'histoire juive, l'histoire européenne. Je pense que pour de nombreux jeunes aujourd'hui,
ne ressentent pas le-- n'ont pas l'impression de porter la responsabilité du colonialisme eux-mêmes.
Ils observent. Donc voilà, des massacres sur lesquels on va revenir un peu plus tard. Ils sont choqués et ils ne font pas forcément le lien avec leurs ancêtres.
Et du coup, cet argument, je pense, tombe un petit peu dans l'oreille d'un sourd. Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Alors, je pense quand même qu'il y a une partie des jeunes qui sont au contraire très sensibles à la question de l'histoire coloniale.
Je dis pas tous, mais je pense qu'il y en a... 'fin, moi, je le vois chez mes étudiants, notamment. Il y a quand même beaucoup de
beaucoup de revendications par rapport à la mémoire coloniale, au fait de reconnaître plus cette mémoire.
Et donc ça passe par des actes de repentance, etc. Je parle de la colonisation de manière générale, notamment celle du Congo, bien évidemment. Mais pas-
Bien sûr. Ce que je voulais dire, c'est qu'on n'est pas dans une situation où on s'empêche de critiquer la situation en Israël en raison de notre histoire collective.
Ah non, au contraire. C'est comme si, au contraire, ça nous... Alors, c'est une interprétation que je fais ici.
J'ai l'impression que ça nous libère un petit peu de la parole anti-israélienne.
Alors, je suis pas psychologue et je vais pas analyser ça sur un plan psychique parce que je sais pas comment ça fonctionne, mais je pense que les mémoires collectives, elles font partie de nos inconscients, nos
inconscients collectifs ici, je parle pas sur le plan individuel, et que quelque part,
on ne peut pas se détacher de nos poids mémoriels quand on commente une situation et quand on commente une situation aussi chargée émotionnellement que celle qui se passe en Israël-Palestine.
Je pense qu'on peut pas faire semblant soit qu'on est neutre ou soit qu'on est juste révolté par l'injustice. Certes, on peut être révolté par l'injustice et je pense que beaucoup de gens le sont très sincèrement.
Je ne remets pas du tout ça en question, mais je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire l'économie en fait d'un examen plus complet, effectivement du rapport à l'histoire, mais d'un rapport à l'histoire qui est multiple.
Encore une fois, c'est pas un rapport monolithique, c'est la manière dont une société s'approprie effectivement les mémoires douloureuses en quelque sorte.
Donc, tu parlais de l'Europe au global et tu disais : « Voilà les mémoires collectives qui font partie de nous, de qui nous sommes aujourd'hui.
» Et c'est intéressant parce qu'en Belgique, on n'en parle pas en fait. Moi, je suis allé à l'école, on n'a jamais parlé du Congo.
Ma mère est née au Congo. C'est tout ce que je sais. J'ai prévu de faire des épisodes là-dessus, mais c'est très compliqué parce que je me rends compte qu'en fait, je pars de nulle part.
Donc, est-ce que tu observes alors des différences entre des pays où on a très fort conscience de, par exemple, l'Algérie française, pour regarder la France,
et quand on compare ça avec le Congo belge dont on ne parle pas du tout en Belgique, est-ce que tu observes alors des rapports différents à la question coloniale, spécifiquement vis-à-vis d'Israël, en fonction des pays dont on parle ?
Alors, ce qui est certain, c'est qu'en Belgique, je vais commencer par dire ça, on a du retard sur ces questions. Ça, c'est très clair.
Parce que c'est quand même rare qu'on puisse donner la France un peu en exemple. C'est très rare. Généralement, elle est à la masse sur à peu près tout, soyons clairs.
Oui, c'est ce genre de dossier en plus.
Oui, c'est ça. Or, il faut quand même reconnaître, même si elle a encore beaucoup de travail à faire aussi en la matière, mais qu'il y a eu reconnaissance officielle des crimes d'Algérie, etc.
Ce qu'il n'y a pas encore eu en Belgique, il y a eu le roi qui a fait une espèce de déclaration-
Il a dit pardon.
C'est ça, mais c'est encore un peu de l'ordre du symbolique. On n'a pas encore une reconnaissance vraiment plénière de l'État belge quoi donc-
Et on n'a pas encore décolonisé notre espace public, etc. Enfin, tout ça, ce sont des choses dont on essaie de parler. Il y a eu cette histoire du rapport sur le Congo belge et la décolonisation qui--
dont le fédéral, je crois, ou je ne sais plus quel gouvernement a essayé d'empêcher la publication.
Tu te souviens de cette affaire ?
Ah oui, je me souviens vaguement. Je me rappelle-
C'est emblématique quand même.
Oui, c'est emblématique. Puis toutes les polémiques qu'il y a eu autour de la refonte du musée de Tervuren aussi, etc. Où en fait, on voit bien qu'on ne sait pas trop quoi faire.
On a tout cet héritage à la fois aussi architectural dans Bruxelles, etc. Et en même temps, on se dit : oui, mais qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ?
On peine effectivement à inclure
cette mémoire-là. Et rappelons aussi, il y a quelques années, moi, je vois ça avec mes étudiants en classe,
les statues de Léopold II qui ont été, entre guillemets, vandalisées, c'est-à-dire généralement, elles étaient couvertes de peinture rouge,
pour revendiquer justement une représentation symbolique de cette colonisation dans l'espace public.
Bon, c'est pas encore... On est à la masse, ça, c'est clair.
On en est aux balbutiements de la question.
Complètement. Alors cela étant dit, par rapport à Israël-Palestine, je pense que quelque part, la question est un peu moins sensible qu'en France, je dirais, pour une autre raison, enfin pour deux raisons, je pense.
D'abord, je pense que justement, l'histoire coloniale française, elle est liée à des territoires musulmans.
Et je pense que ça, c'est quand même un paramètre. Le Congo n'était pas musulman, n'est pas musulman. Alors même si aujourd'hui, il y a de l'islam au Congo, mais on ne va pas rentrer là-dedans.
Mais donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un rapport à la question, notamment de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la question arabe, même si ça n'existe pas, mais en tout cas l'arabe tel qu'on se l'imagine,
le musulman tel qu'on se l'imagine, qui va se rejouer dans le rapport à Israël-Palestine.
Ça, je pense que ça joue. Et je pense aussi que la France n'a pas du tout le même rapport au génocide juif. Ça, c'est très clair.
Je le pense pas, c'est une donnée objective. D'abord, la communauté juive est plus importante en France qu'en Belgique, bien évidemment.
Et d'autre part, la France, c'est Vichy quand même. Je veux dire, la France, il y a un passé collaborationniste qu'on n'a pas en Belgique de la même manière.
Le rapport à l'antisémitisme en France, il est beaucoup plus... Alors, je vais pas dire qu'on n'a pas d'antisémitisme en Belgique.
Bien évidemment, il y a aussi de l'antisémitisme en Belgique, mais il y a quelque chose de beaucoup plus profond historiquement en France.
Beaucoup plus ancré ?
Beaucoup plus ancré culturellement. Moi, ça me fera beaucoup. Je donne énormément de conférences où je parle tout le temps d'antisémitisme, de complotisme, etc.
En Belgique, j'ai jamais entendu à peu près de propos vaguement antisémites dans mes conférences. Je parle... En France, c'est très très régulier.
Et en ce compris, quand je dis antisémite, c'est de l'antisémitisme inconscient, une espèce de formule comme ça où on sent quand même que ouh, il y a un fond un peu puant de ce qu'on est en train de dire.
Cliché bien intégré, bien assimilé.
Ouais, ouais, vraiment.
Tu as des exemples ? Parce que je suis très curieux des exemples de choses que tu as pu entendre dans les conférences qui sont symptomatiques de ce genre d'antisémitisme.
Il faudrait que je me rappelle des exemples précis, mais de manière générale, c'est quand même un peu cette idée que le...
Par exemple, dans la critique des médias, de toujours désigner les Juifs qui seraient derrière les médias et que c'est pour ça que les médias sont comme ils sont.
C'est quelque chose... On peut l'entendre en Belgique aussi, ce genre de cliché, mais on va l'entendre de manière un peu plus sournoise, j'ai envie de dire, en France.
Très underground, on est moins ancré. On va pas l'entendre à la radio quoi.
C'est ça. Il y a un côté moins mainstream. Oui,
c'est plus mainstream en France et par ailleurs très inconscient parce que quand je le dis, comme je parle de ça dans mes conférences, généralement, du coup, je réponds et je dis : « Mais c'est antisémite, ça, comme idée », etc.
Souvent, il y a une espèce d'inconscience de ça. C'est pour ça que je dis que ça peut être de l'antisémitisme inconscient.
C'est-à-dire les gens sont parfois prêts à reconnaître : « Ah oui, OK, peut-être que je nourris un cliché », mais c'est en grande partie inconscient, mais c'est assez décomplexé.
Et donc, ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'en tout cas, ce rapport-là à l'antisémitisme en France, qui est particulier, ce rapport aussi à l'islam, aux musulmans, etc.
Au monde arabe, qui est aussi particulier en France, fait qu'il y a quelque chose qui se rejoue de manière très très forte dans le rapport à Israël-Palestine.
Il y a à la fois toute une communauté juive en France qui, comme la majorité de la communauté juive à travers le monde quand même, soutient Israël, bien évidemment. Et puis, il y a
des communautés arabo-musulmanes d'autre part, mais aussi de gauche, tout simplement, de gauche française, qui vont, pour des raisons historiques, etc, beaucoup plus s'identifier à la question palestinienne et à la cause palestinienne.
Oui, oui. Donc tout ça prend ancrage sur un terrain où c'est déjà un petit peu compliqué. Tu l'as dit, Vichy. Donc ça, c'est pour la France.
On va revenir sur la France et sur ce que ça peut donner, par exemple, dans les institutions, dans les figures politiques françaises.
On va revenir sur la Belgique aussi, évidemment, mais j'aimerais parler d'abord des États-Unis, qui ont encore un rapport très différent avec la situation en Israël et qui semblent être très divisés, semble-t-il, entre
la jeunesse de gauche américaine qui parle beaucoup de Palestine et
les institutions, les
leaders politiques qui
ne cessent de simplement défendre Israël quoi qu'il en soit.
Qu'est-ce qui explique cette situation ?
Les États-Unis, c'est l'allié historique d'Israël quand même. Je veux dire,
c'est un... Et ici, je le dis aussi sans jugement de valeur parce que je pense que le--
même peut-être même positivement, je dirais, parce que je pense que c'était assez logique historiquement, encore une fois, que les États-Unis se placent en défenseur de l'État d'Israël dans la mesure où
c'était l'idée de défendre le peuple juif après ce qui s'était passé.
C'était aussi l'idée de faire une espèce d'axe occidental. Alors, à voir si Israël fait vraiment partie de l'Occident, mais ça, c'est un autre débat.
En tout cas, il y a un lien historique très très profond. Et les gouvernements israéliens sont de grands soutiens, des gouvernements pardon américains sont de grands soutiens d'Israël et je pense que ça ne va pas changer.
Qu'on soit bien clair.
Là, on parle des gouvernements, mais en fait, ça s'observe aussi dans la couverture médiatique. Les gens, les Américains en particulier, voilà, de peut-être un petit peu plus âgés que la jeunesse, vont
être dans une incompréhension totale par rapport au discours de, voilà,
des pro-Palestine pour appeler ça comme ça.
Oui parce qu'il y a-- Je pense qu'il y a dans l'imaginaire collectif américain l'idée que c'est un peu-- Israël est un peu le continuum en quelque sorte des États-Unis ou de l'Occident au Moyen-Orient.
Donc il y a une identification qui est très forte. Puis il y a de forts liens. Beaucoup de Juifs américains sont partis en Israël et vice et versa.
Enfin, je veux dire, c'est des communautés qui sont très mélangées. Par ailleurs, tu parlais de la jeunesse de gauche américaine qui peut être très pro-palestinienne.
Parfois.
Elle est très minoritaire hein.
Voilà.
Soyons bien clairs. On la voit sur les réseaux, etc. Elle représente quasiment rien ni personne. Je caricature mais-
C'est le seul endroit où elle est vraiment représentée, j'aurais tendance à dire. Je ne la vois pas vraiment ailleurs dans le-- Bah c'est vrai qu'il y a certaines émissions qui tapent pas mal sur Netanyahou.
On pourrait y revenir, mais bon, je-- OK, c'est mon prisme et on parlera de la question du prisme et des bulles idéologiques, etc.
C'est que je le vois surtout là, chez les jeunes. Mais peut-être que je me trompe.
Qu'est-ce que tu vois surtout chez les jeunes ? Le soutien à la Palestine ?
Voilà, c'est ça.
Oui, oui, oui.
Cette indignation, disons.
Ben disons que, alors ça, on pourrait faire tout un podcast sur la gauche américaine par ailleurs, parce qu'on a, en tout cas chez la vraie gauche hein.
Je parle pas de la gauche centriste.
Quoi, celle de Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez alors ?
Oui, voilà. Par exemple, on a toute une grille de lecture qui est très anti-impérialiste. C'est-à-dire que c'est l'idée que justement, comme les États-Unis, en gros, dirigent le monde, il faudrait au contraire soutenir tous ceux,
tous ceux qui s'y opposent en quelque sorte.
Et cette gauche américaine anti-impérialiste, soyons clairs, elle va soutenir la Palestine. Elle aura parfois, souvent tendance aussi à être pas très claire sur Bachar al-Assad ou sur Vladimir Poutine.
Et donc on a les biais qu'on retrouve aussi dans la gauche européenne. Mais ces biais-là sont extrêmement forts dans la gauche américaine et c'est par anti-impérialisme.
Donc je pense aussi que là, il y a un peu l'idée : on prend le contrepied du pouvoir et donc on va parfois, de manière pas très subtile...
J'essaye d'être gentille hein. Moi, j'aime pas trop la gauche américaine.
De pincettes, de pincettes dans cette conversation.
Oui, parce que je sais que c'est un sujet sensible et je sais aussi que la gauche américaine, elle vit, on pourrait dire, des oppressions, des persécutions dans le débat public, objectives hein.
C'est-à-dire les minorités aux États-Unis, etc. vivent des choses très difficiles. En plus, si Trump revient, ça va être encore pire.
Donc, je veux pas trop les noircir. En même temps, je sais aussi leur rapport au Moyen-Orient puisque j'ai travaillé sur la Syrie.
Et je les connais hein, les gauchos américains. Généralement, ils trouvent que Assad, quand même, c'est un grand résistant aux États-Unis, quoi.
Donc à un moment donné, forcément, j'ai pas tellement tendance à valoriser leur engagement pour la Palestine, on va dire, parce que je sais avec quoi il va de pair souvent.
Oui. Donc, tu parlais de comment le fait d'avoir de la famille, des amis en Israël impacte le point de vue des choses, l'histoire que tu as rappelée.
Est-ce que le 11 septembre et la perception des Arabes, des musulmans ne vient pas aussi impacter la lecture des choses pour les Américains ?
Très fortement. Le--
Alors, tu sais comment c'est justement un événement sur lequel j'ai beaucoup travaillé, mais je le vois un peu comme le nouveau paradigme des sociétés occidentales, le 11 septembre 2001, et surtout
la couleur qu'on a donnée à cet événement, c'est-à-dire que la couleur que l'administration Bush et ses a-, les alliés de Bush et puis tous les successeurs de Bush aussi
ont donné à cet événement, c'est une couleur extrêmement civilisationnelle.
C'est-à-dire, c'est pas-- On n'a pas paré cet événement en fait d'une aura démocratique. Pas du tout. On lui a donné un sens civilisationnel en présentant
les terroristes comme les barbares et en nous présentant nous comme les civilisés à la manière des croisades hein.
Vraiment, c'était ce,
ce schéma-là.
Sauf que dire que les terroristes d'Al-Qaïda sont des barbares, à la rigueur, on peut être d'accord,
mais très, très vite, il y a eu un glissement sémantique où c'était plus seulement Al-Qaïda qui étaient des barbares, c'était potentiellement le, voilà,
le monde arabo-musulman, on va dire même.
Et donc, je pense qu'effectivement, ça joue encore énormément. En fait, c'est vraiment les deux lignes de fond, hein, qui s'entrecroisent tout le temps, même au Moyen-Orient.
C'est la question de l'antisémitisme et c'est la question de l'islamophobie et de la haine des arabo-musulmans et de la manière dont on a de les présenter toujours comme des menaces.
On voit d'ailleurs que dans la propagande israélienne, la manière de raconter ce qui se passe dans les territoires palestiniens, c'est toujours d'assimiler les Palestiniens au terrorisme.
C'est-- Alors, je pense qu'il y a du terrorisme palestinien, bien évidemment,
mais ça veut dire qu'il y a un vocabulaire qui est utilisé, qui va tout le temps réactiver le schéma civilisationnel, qui effectivement parle à beaucoup d'Américains.
Parce qu'en plus, il ne faut pas oublier que beaucoup d'Américains ont été faire la guerre en Irak, ont été faire la guerre en Afghanistan, ont perdu des gens de leur famille, ont perdu des jeunes hommes.
Donc, il y a aussi un affect qui est très fort. Alors, l'Afghanistan, c'est plus loin, bien évidemment, mais en tout cas au Moyen-Orient aussi quoi, ça, c'est clair.
Donc, on voit que l'histoire, voilà, des trois pays qu'on a évoqués vient donner forme à ces différents niveaux, différentes formes d'antisémitisme, d'islamophobie.
Et c'est sur ce terrain-là que vont largement se construire des positionnements pro-Israël, pro-Palestine, etc.
Ce qui est intéressant également, c'est le fait que, voilà, je l'évoquais, on l'évoquait ensemble il y a un instant, la question des bulles idéologiques.
Le qu'est-ce que tu vois dans ton feed Instagram, dans ton feed TikTok. Et quelqu'un me disait au téléphone : « Moi, je ne vois que des trucs pro-Israël.
» Chose que je vous avoue que moi, je ne vois pas ça dans mon feed. Est-ce qu'on observe alors un changement-
Global, civilisationnel, je ne sais pas, à grande échelle disons, de la lecture de la situation en Israël à cause ou en partie à cause de ces algorithmes qui nous enferment dans des bulles idéologiques.
Alors bon bien sûr, on ne peut pas nier que ce soit une composante. Cela étant dit, moi, j'ai toujours-- quand on me pose ce type de questions, j'ai toujours tendance à rappeler que même avant Internet, on avait
on avait tendance à s'enfermer avec des gens qui pensent comme nous.
Je veux dire, c'est une tendance un peu naturelle de fréquenter les lieux, les espaces, etc. où on va avoir des gens qui vont nourrir notre discours.
Et je pense que vraiment, personne n'échappe à ça, vraiment.
Mais disons qu'à très grande échelle, avec des algorithmes surpuissants-
Voilà.
Ça donne un sérieux coup d'accélérateur à cette mécanique-là.
C'est ça. Et je pense que le problème, c'est que ça peut nous faire déconnecter, alors d'abord ici de manière générale, de la réalité, parce qu'on a l'impression, par exemple, que tout le monde pense de telle manière,
alors qu'en réalité, effectivement, ça peut être une minorité.
On a chacun notre réalité.
Oui, c'est ça. Et ça devient extrêmement dangereux, évidemment, parce que sur quoi peut-on encore s'appuyer de manière commune si on n'a pas une réalité partagée ?
Donc oui, je pense que ça joue, mais ce qui joue aussi beaucoup là-dedans, c'est la propagande qui vient s'infiltrer, justement.
C'est que malheureusement ou heureusement, enfin, c'est une réalité, j'en sais rien. Si c'est heureux ou malheureux, c'est plutôt malheureux sans doute.
C'est que les acteurs idéologiques, quels qu'ils soient, ils ont compris les logiques justement algorithmiques, etc. Et ils les utilisent pour vendre leur récit.
Et c'est-à-dire que moi, c'est plutôt ça qui m'inquiète en quelque sorte, c'est cette existence de récits préfabriqués, hein.
C'est des récits clés en main qui vont
se décliner sous différents supports, que ce soit sous support visuel, beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux, surtout Instagram, par exemple, ça va être surtout visuel, mais ça peut être aussi sous la forme de tweets, etc.
Ou de vidéos ou que sais-je, et qui vont en fait tout le temps marteler. En fait, c'est ça un récit de propagande.
Il va tout le temps marteler la même histoire et sur-
Cimenter une réalité.
Voilà. Il va appuyer tout le temps sur le même clou. Et alors, à un moment donné, bien évidemment que tous ceux qui suivent ce narratif-là vont être persuadés que ce narratif correspond à l'exacte réalité. Alors,
on a tous besoin de récits, hein. Donc avoir un récit, s'accrocher à un récit, c'est pas que négatif, je le répète toujours aussi,
mais pour autant qu'on sache bien quels sont les tenants et les aboutissants de ce récit et qui le dirige, en quelque sorte.
Si, je vais reprendre l'exemple de la Syrie, si c'est un récit, par exemple, qui est vendu par des propagandistes de Bachar al-Assad, ben le problème, c'est que c'est un récit qui va au final servir des crimes de guerre quoi.
Je prends l'exemple de la Syrie, comme tu vois, pour ne pas m'aventurer sur la question des crimes en cours en Israël-Palestine.
Mais c'est pour bien dire que effectivement, cette cohabitation de récits, cette d'une multitude de récits, en fait, sur des mêmes événements, c'est un des gros problèmes actuels.
Et moi, c'est mon travail, c'est ça qui m'intéresse,
c'est d'essayer de décortiquer ces récits et de comprendre-- et c'est pas
tomber non plus dans du relativisme en disant : il y a aucun récit qui est correct ou qui est bon ou qui est-- oui, je pense qu'il y a des récits qui sont meilleurs que d'autres.
Je pense par exemple que le récit qui défend la démocratie et les droits humains est globalement meilleur que celui qui va défendre les dictatures.
Ça, c'est très clair. Mais il faut juste avoir conscience de quel récit on a et celui qu'on porte et qui est derrière quoi, en quelque sorte.
Ouais, ouais. Mais donc ça, c'est pour la question donc des flux qui nous ciblent individuellement. À côté de ça, il y a les médias mainstream.
Et donc c'est un petit peu là-dessus qu'on va avoir l'occasion d'échanger, je pense, aujourd'hui. Il y a eu des exemples très intéressants.
Celui qui m'a le plus frappé, c'est-- enfin, il y en a plusieurs qui m'ont frappé très fort, c'est,
il y avait eu cet épisode où certains, certaines politiciens, politiciennes en Belgique et en France ne souhaitaient pas forcément qualifier le Hamas comme étant un groupe terroriste.
Zakia Khattabi, ici en Belgique, Jean-Luc Mélenchon, par exemple, entre autres, en France. Et on observait une couverture médiatique sanglante, sanguinaire, qui n'acceptait pas cette réponse-là.
Alors, on va parler d'abord de la Belgique. Celle qui m'a le plus frappé, celle qui était la plus dure, je pense, de mémoire, c'était plutôt celle de La Libre Belgique, média plutôt à droite,
qui donc, voilà, comme je le disais, n'acceptait pas du tout la réponse de Zakia Khattabi. Qu'est-ce que
ça disait de la situation ? Comment expliquer que sa réponse était autant mal reçue ? Donc ce qu'elle essayait de dire, c'est qu'elle se basait sur le droit international et que
l'action, l'attentat était évidemment terroriste, qu'il était évidemment à condamner,
mais qu'elle n'était pas hyper sûre de pouvoir être en mesure de dire que le Hamas était un groupe terroriste.
Ouais, je me rappelle, ouais.
Et cette nuance-là était inacceptable. Moi, voilà, je regardais ça de loin sans trop savoir qui avait raison, qui avait tort, mais je me souviens qu'il y avait une-- médiatiquement, un refus d'accepter cette réponse-là.
Ouais ouais, je me souviens très bien. Je me souviens aussi d'une dynamique similaire en France, mais c'est vrai qu'en Belgique, ça a été aussi très fort sur Zakia Khattabi.
En fait, c'est parce qu'on a un enjeu symbolique autour de la question du terrorisme qui est justement lié à l'après 11 septembre.
On sait que quand on met l'étiquette terrorisme, en réalité, dans le paradigme post 11 septembre 2001, eh ben, on peut justifier toutes les violences à l'égard de ceux qui sont désignés comme terrorisme.
Ça facilite un petit peu la lecture des choses, c'est un petit peu plus manichéen, un petit peu plus binaire.
Bah oui, parce qu'on sait, si t'es terroriste, t'es vraiment au-delà de toutes les lignes rouges quoi. Alors, soyons clairs, il y a effectivement des définitions juridiques, etc.
Et moi, je suis pas-- alors là, je parle juste de moi, je suis pas du genre à chipoter. Pour moi, le Hamas, c'est clair que c'est terroriste, que l'attentat qu'il y a eu, c'est terroriste.
Chose urgente.
J'ai pas du tout envie et ça me met mal à l'aise, en fait, les gens qui commencent à jouer sur les mots. Mais je-- alors donc moi, je suis pas du tout de cette ligne-là.
Je ne dis pas personnellement par rapport à Zakia Khattabi, je le dis vraiment de manière générale. Je n'aime pas quand on ergote personnellement.
Je trouve que c'est souvent-- ça ouvre la porte à des choses pas très belles.
Oui, et c'est un petit peu inquiétant. On se demande pourquoi insister là-dessus.
C'est ça. Et voilà. Et pourquoi commencer à pinailler là-dessus alors que sur d'autres trucs, on va pas pinailler ? Bon, bref.
Et même, on se dit : Mais en matière de communication politique, dans une année électorale, mais quel choix étrange ? Mais ouais.
Je pense que c'est des loyautés politiques. C'est aussi, justement un refus de diaboliser, non pas à mon avis, par exemple, Zakia Khattabi, je pense pas une seule seconde qu'elle soit pro Hamas, en soi, bien évidemment-
Je pense pas non plus.
Mais une peur qu'on diabolise les Palestiniens et la résistance palestinienne. Je pense qu'il doit y avoir ça. Alors ça, c'est mon hypothèse.
Et donc surtout, peur d'alimenter justement cette opposition entre civilisés, barbares, etc. Je pense que c'est de cet ordre-là.
Mais moi, je suis pas d'accord avec ça. Mais ce qui est vrai, c'est que, a contrario, donc je suis pas d'accord avec le type de position de Zakia Khattabi.
A contrario, quand je vois des gens qui vont mettre une énergie folle à dire à quel point ce que le Hamas a fait est horrible et c'est horrible.
Moi, ça m'a vraiment traumatisée à titre personnel, ces attaques. En plus, c'était la veille de mon accouchement.
Enfin bon, bref, donc ça s'est passé dans des circonstances où j'étais dans un état assez fébrile, on va dire. Et donc apprendre ces événements, ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup marquée.
Mais les gens qui vont passer toute leur énergie à condamner ces attaques atroces, mais qui ne vont jamais utiliser le même type de discours sur les crimes israéliens à Gaza.
Bien évidemment que là, on voit qu'il y a aussi un problème parce qu'on voit que justement, le terme terrorisme va être désigné pour
en quelque sorte jeter hors de l'humanité certains groupes armés et au contraire, pour préserver d'autres groupes armés, puisque l'armée israélienne, c'est un groupe armé.
Alors pas un groupe armé qui est assimilable au Hamas, parce qu'on a une armée d'un pays d'un côté et on a un groupe terroriste de l'autre.
'Fin, mais en tout cas, c'est quand même un groupe armé. Et refuser absolument
d'examiner les actes de l'armée israélienne, les actes, ben les mauvais actes, je sais pas comment le dire, de l'armée israélienne,
au nom justement de cette espèce de manichéisme, là, par contre, j'ai aussi beaucoup de problèmes.
Donc tu penses que c'est ça le moteur premier de ces mécaniques-là ?
Ah oui, je pense.
C'est une facilité de lecture, une-- on simplifie le récit, on présente quelque chose de très noir et blanc et c'est plus simple à présenter, plus simple à lire.
Oui, et ça dédouane, soyons clairs, hein, ça participait de dédouaner la riposte israélienne. Puisque si c'est des attaques terroristes, encore une fois, ce que c'est, c'était, c'est très clair,
mais on peut alors justifier ben une riposte à la hauteur de l'horreur du sept octobre.
Le problème, c'est : qui mesure ce qui est à la hauteur de l'attaque du sept octobre ? C'est-à-dire, qui mesure si une riposte est proportionnée ou pas ?
Si c'est l'armée israélienne elle-même qui doit mesurer la riposte, ben on voit qu'à un moment donné, ça peut aller loin, on va dire.
Trop loin. Ouais, on peut juste rappeler un petit peu les faits, hein. Donc on a récemment dépassé les quarante mille victimes du côté de la Palestine, dont une très grande majorité de civils, trente pour cent d'enfants.
Donc vraiment, on est loin de-- parce qu'ils présentent les choses en disant que c'est très ciblé, qu'ils envoient des flyers avant de faire des bombardements, etc.
Des SMS, ouais.
Ouais. Bon, c'est pas hyper cohérent. Il y a aussi eu des agences de presse, Reuters, je crois. Je ne sais plus laquelle c'était, mais des agences de presse qui se sont fait bombarder.
On ne sait pas pourquoi. Voilà. Mais donc voilà, je vais revenir simplement. Donc ça, c'était pour reposer un petit peu le contexte puisque tu évoquais donc une réponse disproportionnée.
Donc ça, c'était pour le cas de Zakia Khattabi.
Intéressons-nous quelques instants à la France. Et donc il y avait ce cas très particulier de Jean-Luc Mélenchon, également dans une année électorale, de leur côté, pour les élections européennes.
Et il ne le savait pas encore, mais législatives également.
Oui.
Voilà, qui fait le choix de défendre mordicus l'idée que non, non, je n'ai pas envie de dire que le Hamas, c'est un groupe terroriste.
Mais là, c'était face à une insistance, à une indignation de toute la classe, oui, médiatico-politique. Il ne souhaitait pas, il refusait d'ajuster son discours.
Quelle était ta lecture de cet épisode-là ?
Bon alors déjà, je vais mettre tout de suite sur la table que je n'aime pas du tout politiquement Jean-Luc Mélenchon. Je préfère le dire parce que pour ceux qui suivent mon travail, ils sont au courant.
Puisque je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui, justement, comment dire
? Surfe beaucoup sur certains clivages et sur une certaine polarisation et pense qu'en accentuant une certaine polarisation et parfois sur le dos des minorités, ça va servir son agenda politique.
Quand je dis parfois sur le dos des minorités, c'est que pour moi, Jean-Luc Mélenchon est quelqu'un qui n'hésite pas certaines fois à
faire les choses sur le dos de la minorité juive ou sur le dos de la minorité musulmane parce qu'il pense que ça va être bankable politiquement.
Et je pense que très clairement, ici, c'est ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'il s'est dit, il a fait une espèce de calcul. Je pense que c'est opportuniste.
C'est ma lecture des choses, hein, bien évidemment, de se dire : Ben si
l'État français de manière générale, ou en tout cas les personnes qui sont au pouvoir sont dans le soutien inconditionnel d'Israël, moi, je dois montrer que je suis l'alternative, en quelque sorte.
C'est cette fameuse polarisation entre ce qui serait la position officielle et ce qui serait la position alternative.
Presque contrarien, comme dynamique. C'est : on ne veut pas faire comme le chef.
Je pense que c'est beaucoup de ça.
Oui.
Et je pense aussi que c'est pour flatter évidemment une partie des militants dont on sait qu'ils sont, 'fin
plus qu'une partie, hein, une très grande part des militants qui sont dans un logiciel aussi très anti-impérialiste et donc pour certains qui peuvent voir dans le Hamas
une résistance à
Israël et à l'Occident, on pourrait dire ça comme ça.
Encore une fois, à travers le prisme de l'anticolonialisme.
Complètement, anticolonialisme, anti-impérialisme. Quand je disais que je n'aimais pas Mélenchon, c'est la même, c'est le,
la même logique qui l'a fait être si complaisant avec Assad hein, puisque aussi Assad était vu dans son schéma, dans ce schéma-là comme quelque part un résistant justement à l'Occident et donc peut-être pas quelqu'un de si mauvais que ça.
Je simplifie ici hein, juste pour donner l'idée. Donc là, je pense qu'on a aussi des vieilles lectures qui sont encore présentes et sur lesquelles Mélenchon-- Par exemple, je crois pas qu'à titre personnel, il soit convaincu de ça.
Que, je pense que lui, à mon avis, à titre personnel, doit penser que le Hamas est terroriste. Mais alors ça, c'est juste mon hypothèse.
Oui oui, c'est une pure spéculation, mais je veux dire, je pense pas que c'est tant de l'ordre de la conviction que de l'ordre
De la manœuvre politique.
De la manœuvre, de la manœuvre politique et aussi de nourrir un narratif, encore une fois. De nourrir un narratif qui est : il y aurait, d'un côté,
les oppresseurs et puis les autres qui résistent aux oppresseurs, peut-être qu'ils ne résistent pas très bien, pas vraiment de la bonne manière, mais qui sont quand même ceux qui résistent aux oppresseurs.
Et je pense qu'il veut tellement nourrir ce narratif-là
qu'il en vient à ce genre de position. C'est effectivement mon analyse et une spéculation de ma part,
mais c'est pour dire que je crois que quand on ergote, entre guillemets, sur des choses aussi graves,
bon d'abord, je trouve ça très grave politiquement, honnêtement, parce que c'est assez inconscient et inconsidéré, mais généralement, c'est qu'on pense quand même que symboliquement, lâcher, par exemple ici, le mot terrorisme
nous en coûterait trop.
Je pense que c'est, il doit y avoir derrière un calcul, un calcul politique, un calcul électoraliste hein, je sais pas comment le dire ça comme ça.
Et qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de la réponse alors de l'appareil médiatique, politique, de voilà, tous ces médias qui étaient indignés ?
Est-ce que ça te semble légitime ou bien disproportionné ?
Alors c'est par ailleurs, alors là, je vais rebasculer dans l'autre sens, c'est totalement disproportionné. Puis en France, il y a un Mélenchon bashing qui est-
Oui.
Qui est en fait une haine de la gauche. Je le dis d'autant plus que je viens de dire que moi, j'aime pas Mélenchon.
Donc je suis très à l'aise pour le dire. C'est qu'il y a une diabolisation de la gauche qui passe à travers la diabolisation de Mélenchon.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'extrême centrisme un petit peu. C'est l'idée que voilà, il y a le centre, le raisonnable, peut-être le PS, peut-être un petit peu les Républicains.
Mais si on va plus loin que ça, c'est inaudible. On peut même pas entendre, on peut pas considérer ces discours-là.
Oui, c'est l'idée d'assimiler la gauche à quelque chose d'extrême et de radical, et donc d'en faire l'espèce d'équivalent de l'extrême droite.
C'est vraiment tout à fait ce qui se passe en France hein, de manière très caricaturale. Et voire même, parfois, on se demande s'ils présentent pas la gauche comme plus dangereuse que l'extrême droite hein.
Et donc effectivement, se présenter comme le camp de la raison, là, je parle du camp de Macron hein, qui va se présenter comme le camp de la raison, le camp du centre, etc.
Et qui va donc se servir, encore une fois, c'est un narratif en réalité, on en revient toujours à ça, qui va se servir de cette position pour discréditer toutes les luttes de gauche.
Et donc c'est pour ça, moi, autant j'ai toujours combattu des gens comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon et je vais continuer parce que je les aime pas du tout politiquement, autant je sais tout à fait reconnaître aussi quand on les attaque pour les mauvaises
raisons
et quand on les attaque pour en fait nous attaquer tous, parce que je me considère de gauche, bien évidemment.
Et donc on a ce paradigme-là, malheureusement, qui est très fort en place en France. Et comme la question palestinienne est quand même très ancrée à gauche, il faut pas l'oublier hein,
et qu'on est dans un moment politique où, en gros, la gauche est diabolisée à mort hein, on va pas se mentir, forcément, ben,
la lutte palestinienne pâtit aussi de la configuration actuelle du débat public. Ça, c'est clair.
Donc, puisque là, on lisait donc les choses à travers le prisme de cet hypercentrisme, extrême centrisme, de voilà, on ne peut pas entendre, la gauche est aussi inacceptable, inentendable, inaudible que l'extrême droite.
Donc ça, c'est, voilà, une manœuvre politique, des positionnements politiques en campagne. Mais pour revenir donc à la question effectivement du Mélenchon bashing qui a eu lieu à ce moment-là, dans cet épisode-là,
ce qui est toujours frappant, c'est à quel point ce ne sont pas uniquement les politiques qui condamnent, mais c'est l'ensemble de la classe médiatique, les journalistes, voilà, sur France Télévisions, sur BFM, etc.
Et là, il y a quelque chose qui chaque fois m'étonne, me surprend. Comment est-ce que tu expliques ça ?
Alors, je pense que là, il y a quand même en partie une particularité française, même si ça se joue aussi un petit peu de la même manière en Belgique, mais je trouve de manière moins caricaturale.
C'est qu'en France, il y a une proximité quand même très grande en termes de réseau, tout simplement hein, entre les milieux médiatiques et les milieux politiques.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, il y a un petit monde hein. Et évidemment, c'est pas un complot hein, je suis pas dans une rhétorique conspirationniste.
C'est simplement un petit monde parisien. Moi, je l'ai pas mal vu et je le vois pas mal parce que je suis quand même souvent dans les médias en France et tout.
C'est qu'on voit bien que c'est tous des gens qui se font la bise, qui se connaissent et qui, voilà, qui vont dans les mêmes dîners.
Et donc il y a une proximité idéologique qui, pour moi, est en fait un petit peu un des héritages de l'Ancien Régime en France.
Moi, j'ai vraiment cette thèse que la France n'a jamais quitté l'Ancien Régime et qu'elle a une espèce
d'élite comme ça qui est à Paris avec le prince et puis sa cour, en quelque sorte, et cette cour, elle est un petit peu dans les médias, elle est un petit peu dans les sphères politiques, dans les sphères diplomatiques, etc.
Et malheureusement, ça fait énormément de mal et ça nourrit aussi le conspirationnisme, je pense. Cette configuration qui est en fait une configuration encore une fois historique.
Je suis désolée, je suis historienne, je vois toujours tout par le prisme de l'histoire, mais je crois vraiment beaucoup à ça.
C'est une manière dont la société française est structurée, mais qui renforce une espèce de clivage de plus en plus grand entre ce qu'on peut se représenter comme les élites et puis le reste de la population.
On le voit pour le moment, je vais faire quand même un tout petit lien avec le féminisme hein, puisque vous savez que ça me tient à cœur, ben avec la promotion dont jouit Caroline Fourest, par exemple.
Oui, c'est récent, ça.
Oui, ça, c'est vraiment très très récent puisqu'elle vient sortir un bouquin où elle bash MeToo hein, on va pas rentrer là-dedans.
Tu emploies le mot néo-féministe ou ?
Oui, oui, bien évidemment.
C'est quand même un bon red flag. Ça pose le contexte.
Oui, oui, oui, c'est, mais c'est tout à fait situé. D'ailleurs hein, son bouquin, elle s'assume plutôt bien, il faut lui reconnaître quand même.
Et mais elle est invitée absolument partout tout le temps. Et c'est quelque chose qui, en tout cas vu de l'extérieur, on se dit : Mais comment ça se fait ?
C'est pas possible. Et en fait, c'est dû à ce microcosme. Et je dis ça parce que du coup, c'est vrai que ça donne une vision biaisée.
On a l'impression qu'il y a— ou bien alors que tous les médias pensent la même chose, que tout le monde a le même discours.
En fait, oui, tout le monde a le même discours, mais c'est un tout petit groupe de gens qui souvent ne représentent pas l'ensemble de la population, bien évidemment.
Bon, à quoi il faut rajouter éventuellement le cas spécial des médias Bolloré, etc. qui ont-
En plus, qui ont accentué le truc.
Le même discours, mais encore plus à droite. Ce qui est intéressant également, c'est qu'il y a quatre ans, quand on a fait cet épisode de podcast ensemble, tu citais le cas de Yann Moix.
Yann Moix n'a pas disparu des médias-
Non.
Alors qu'il a de sérieux psycholattes dans son placard. Donc voilà, c'est un bon exemple encore de ce que tu viens d'évoquer.
En termes d'antisémitisme, notamment.
Également, voilà. Donc ça nous rapproche-
Rappelons-le.
Ça nous rapproche du sujet sur lequel je voulais revenir maintenant. Un autre cas qui était intéressant, donc toujours en France, c'était la question du groupe qui possède BFMTV,
groupe qui possède également donc un média en Israël.
Et donc il y a eu ce cas très particulier où la couverture médiatique des événements, voilà, liés au sept octobre et des semaines et des mois qui ont suivi, était réalisée par les équipes israéliennes de ce média.
J'ai oublié le nom, malheureusement, je sais pas si-
C'est pas i24NEWS ? Parce que moi, je ne sais pas de quel média tu parles, donc...
C'est potentiellement celui-là. Bon, je vais vérifier pendant que tu me réponds, mais donc il y avait cette problématique de
la rédaction de BFM qui en fait, finalement, n'était pas en mesure de couvrir les événements en Israël parce que, ben les Israéliens le faisaient pour eux.
Ça, c'était un cas assez particulier.
Alors effectivement, ça, c'est un problème. Rajoutons à ça le fait que les journalistes n'ont pas un accès libre à Gaza en plus, hein.
Donc on a aussi le fait que même les journalistes ne peuvent pas faire leur travail correctement. Donc il y a un problème de couverture évidemment, qui est assez fort.
Et il y a aussi par ailleurs, justement avec le biais qu'on disait juste avant, ben en fait malheureusement, une homogénéité quand même assez grande de la manière de voir les choses au sein des médias.
Donc même si y avait pas de collaboration avec une chaîne israélienne, tu as sans doute retrouvé la référence du coup.
Oui, donc c'est effectivement-
C'est i24NEWS, oui.
Donc qui est possédée par ou qui est-- Je suis en train de vérifier si ça n'a pas changé récemment, mais donc qui était possédée par Patrick Drahi.
Ah oui, c'est Drahi, oui, oui.
Avec BFM, RMC, etc.
Bon, par exemple, pour nuancer tout de suite, moi, j'ai donné pas mal d'interviews dans les mois qui ont suivi
le sept octobre pour un peu décoder les questions de propagande, des deux côtés, hein, que ce soit propagande du Hamas et propagande du gouvernement israélien.
J'ai été invitée sur BFM, et je veux dire alors que je suis pas-
On s'en souvient.
Voilà, et je suis pas une pro-israélienne, voilà. Donc ça veut dire, il faut pas non plus caricaturer. Il y a toujours...
Y a évidemment le problème de ligne éditoriale qui peut, qui doit être examiné.
Mais ça n'empêche pas qu'un média, il y a toujours au sein des médias des journalistes de bonne volonté, des gens qui essayent de mettre de la pluralité dans le débat, etc.
Donc je pense qu'il faut faire toujours attention. À la fois, il faut être évidemment attentif à qui détient quoi et quelle est l'influence, etc., etc.
C'est hyper important. Qui fait les images, qui fait les reportages, ça, c'est des questions de base, bien sûr.
Je pense pour autant qu'il faut toujours essayer de garder quand même en tête qu'on est en démocratie, hein, heureusement, et que donc on est quand même dans une culture de la pluralité.
Et donc moi, j'ai jamais--
Je peux vous dire que quand j'ai été invitée pour parler d'Israël-Palestine ces derniers mois, je faisais toujours très attention et j'ai
décliné pas mal d'interviews parce que j'ai très peur de parler de ce sujet, comme à peu près tout le monde, je pense.
Mais je n'ai jamais eu d'instruction où on m'a dit : « Ah non, tu peux pas parler de ça », etc. Donc, je pense qu'il faut parfois aussi un peu démystifier.
C'est pas tant qu'on interdit certaines paroles, c'est juste qu'il y a un microcosme, encore une fois, un entre-soi.
C'est souvent ça en fait le problème qui fait que ce sont toujours les mêmes personnes qui vont commenter les choses et qu'elles sont souvent du même avis.
Et donc ça donne une coloration qui peut être biaisée, bien évidemment. Mais je pense aussi que le fait que les journalistes ne peuvent pas aller à Gaza-
Oui.
A énormément biaisé l'information de manière générale.
Oui, tout à fait. Donc pour revenir à la Belgique, qu'est-ce que tu as pu observer vis-à-vis de la couverture médiatique dans nos médias ?
Puisque là, on a parlé l'espace d'un instant de, par exemple, de BFM et consorts. Qu'est-ce que tu as pu observer en Belgique ?
Je trouve que comme souvent, les choses sont un peu moins caricaturales qu'en France. On va être clair.
C'est toujours mieux en Belgique.
Non, mais c'est vrai. En France, on a l'impression que tout est toujours plus marqué, plus fort. En Belgique, j'ai quand même l'impression que, comment dire ?
Cette idée que tous les médias auraient le même parti pris pro-israélien, etc., c'est quand même moins le cas, je trouve.
Je trouve que par exemple, la RTBF, elle a fait pas mal de chouettes sujets sur ce qui se passait à Gaza, etc.
Alors, ça veut pas dire que... 'Fin, c'est difficile d'évaluer une couverture médiatique qui serait cent pour cent objective, hein, bien évidemment.
Mais ça n'existe pas, je pense, effectivement. Mais je pense quand même que, 'fin, je trouve, de ce que j'ai vu en Belgique, c'est que même si tout n'est pas parfait,
il y a quand même, disons, des choses qui sont un peu moins figées, et un discours qui est peut-être parfois un peu moins idéologisé qu'en France sur ce conflit, hein.
Là, je parle bien de ce conflit-là.
Oui, oui. Et donc effectivement, il me semble avoir entendu que la RTBF avait été critiquée par certains positionnements, ben critiquée parce qu'elle aurait une couverture médiatique un petit peu trop pro-Palestine.
Voilà, bon, ça, c'est évidemment la lecture de-
Oui, moi, je trouve qu'ils essayent de faire vraiment, de couvrir les deux quoi. J'ai l'impression que justement, ils essayent d'être dans une certaine-- alors neutralité, c'est jamais possible d'être neutre, objectivité en tout cas.
Ouais, en tout cas, quelque chose de pas trop partisan.
C'est ça.
Voilà. Oui, il y a quelques jours, Thomas, il interviewait l'ambassadrice d'Israël en Belgique. Et voilà, effectivement, c'était pas un clash, c'était très poli.
Oui, c'est ça.
Un autre événement qui m'avait marqué pendant cette année, en Belgique, c'était l'occupation des campus. Donc ça-
Ah oui, oui.
Il y en a eu ici en Belgique, il y en a eu aussi également en France. Commençons par la Belgique et aux États-Unis d'ailleurs aussi.
Oui.
Commençons par la Belgique. Donc, je me souviens de ces images de l'ULB avec la pelouse à côté du bâtiment K à l'ULB, au Solbosch.
Il y avait un bâtiment qui avait été occupé.
Oui, oui, c'est ça.
Et la rectrice avait... Oui, voilà, je me rappelle en posant la question. La rectrice avait
demandé que ça cesse et puis ça ne s'était pas arrêté et elle avait fini par faire quelques concessions, notamment, et ça avait pas mal choqué dans le... Tu fais partie du monde académique, donc tu vas pouvoir me donner ton avis.
Mais il y avait la question d'interrompre les travaux de recherche menés en collaboration avec des universités israéliennes qui faisaient partie des demandes de ces étudiants qui ont vraiment été dans une position, comment dire, de
j'allais dire radicale, mais voilà, de, on ne veut...
Du boycott.
Voilà, c'est ça, un boycott total. On ne veut plus rien avoir à faire avec Israël. Donc, on souhaite que notre université arrête de travailler avec des universités israéliennes.
Et ça a fini par se faire, ce qui moi m'a surpris et ce qui a surpris pas mal de professeurs d'université. Comment est-ce que tu as lu cette séquence ?
Alors déjà, je l'ignorais que ça avait abouti. Je ne pensais pas que ça avait été écouté en quelque sorte.
Il y a eu une lettre ouverte de plein de professeurs de l'ULB d'ailleurs, qui étaient vraiment choqués par cette...
Ah ben voilà, ça, je l'ai loupé. Je suis toujours très perplexe sur la question du boycott et surtout de la question du boycott académique et culturel en réalité.
Parce que le boycott économique, ça, c'est une chose. On peut décider de boycotter une série de produits et tout. Bon, après, il y a toujours la question : où s'arrête le boycott et où il commence ?
Bon, c'est complexe hein. Mais quand c'est du boycott académique et culturel, alors, je peux comprendre le principe de dire : on ne collabore plus du tout avec un État dont on estime qu'il est en train de commettre des crimes de guerre, etc.
Sur le principe, je peux comprendre. Le problème, à mes yeux, c'est qu'on se coupe aussi de la société israélienne en faisant ça.
Parce que les relations académiques, les relations dans le monde culturel, c'est ce qui permet de continuer à être en lien avec une société qui est quand même une société démocratique.
Rappelons-le, Israël est une société... enfin, en tout cas pour les Israéliens, Israël est une démocratie hein, soyons clairs.
Et donc ça veut dire qu'il y a cette tradition, justement, en démocratie, du pluralisme, du dialogue, etc., etc. Et moi, je trouve dommage de se couper des citoyens israéliens.
Alors que ça vienne du monde universitaire, je trouve ça justement un petit peu ironique quelque part, parce que normalement, le monde universitaire devrait être celui qui continue à nourrir des liens intellectuels.
Ça, c'est vraiment ma vision à moi hein. Maintenant, la jeunesse universitaire est traditionnellement une jeunesse militante et ça, je trouve ça très bien.
Et qu'elle ait des revendications de type symbolique, je peux le comprendre. Je sais qu'il y avait eu aussi un autre problème à l'ULB, c'est qu'ils avaient chahuté, ou essayé d'empêcher la venue d'Élie Barnavi.
Je ne sais pas si tu te rappelles de ça.
Oui, tout à fait, oui. Qui n'est d'ailleurs pas tellement un pro Netanyahou.
C'est ça, qui est un anti Netanyahou complet.
Voilà, qui est plutôt pour une solution à deux États, si je dis pas de bêtises. Voilà, c'est révélateur de quelque chose.
Je te laisse continuer.
Oui, ben, c'était juste pour dire que là aussi, j'avais été un peu perplexe quoi, parce qu'ils étaient sur une position de principe, parce que c'est un ancien ambassadeur d'Israël en Belgique, etc.
Donc évidemment, il y a l'idée... Et puis il est, voilà,
il est Israélien, il est... Enfin, voilà, il a tout son lien avec ce pays, mais en même temps, typiquement, c'est quelqu'un qui, justement,
est un ferme opposant à Netanyahou, qui non seulement est pour les deux États, mais aussi appelle depuis plusieurs semaines, sans doute mois maintenant, à un cessez-le-feu à Gaza, etc. Donc
qui est quand même engagé. Alors, c'est pas non plus un extrême gauchiste hein, on est bien d'accord, mais quand même, voilà, il est... Ce sont des voix qui s'opposent au gouvernement en place en Israël
et donc les boycotter ou essayer d'empêcher leur venue.
Alors, je peux le comprendre dans l'esprit vraiment militant, de demander des symboles. Je peux comprendre l'intention.
Je suis pas persuadée que ce soit la meilleure voie, en tout cas pour ce conflit spécifiquement, qui est quand même un conflit très spécifique justement, puisqu'on a une société israélienne
avec qui je pense, il y a encore moyen de communiquer au niveau des citoyens.
Là, je parle pas du tout des gouvernements, etc. Mais on a des gens qui vont dans les universités, qui vont dans des... enfin, qui voyagent, qui pour beaucoup sont originaires d'Europe à la base, etc.
Et donc j'ai le sentiment que c'est des gens avec qui on a intérêt à entretenir un lien, tout comme on a tout à fait intérêt à entretenir les liens avec les Palestiniens qui sont aussi un
peuple très, comment dire, avec un taux, je sais pas si tu le sais ça, mais un taux d'inscription dans les universités extrêmement élevé, etc.
C'est un... J'aime pas dire que c'est un peuple très cultivé parce que ça fait cliché de dire ça, mais on comprend ce que je veux dire.
Il y a une vie universitaire, une vie académique, une vie culturelle qui est très très forte dans les territoires.
En fait, à la fois dans les territoires palestiniens et dans les territoires israéliens. Et je trouve que se couper de ça,
c'est un petit peu se couper d'une possible possibilité de s'appuyer sur les sociétés civiles pour qu'il y ait un changement là-bas.
Aussi bien du côté palestinien qu'israélien en fait.
Ce qui moi me semblait révélateur, c'était mais presque une lecture, comme on le disait tout à l'heure, mais très binaire en fait.
C'est : ah, c'est israélien, ce sont des chercheurs israéliens. Ah, c'est une personnalité israélienne qui vient. Donc c'est non, donc ça dégage, donc on arrête tout.
C'est le symbole.
Qui, mais qui... Alors, et là on s'approche d'un autre sujet, une autre critique qui est revenue très régulièrement, la critique de : Tiens, on attaque Netanyahou, on attaque Israël, on est donc antisémites.
Bon, c'est ridicule si on me demande mon avis, mais, dans le cas de cette manœuvre à l'ULB, il y avait malgré tout cet aspect, on déteste Israël quoi.
Et ça, on ne veut plus rien avoir à faire avec eux, boycott total, très très manichéen, oui.
Ben disons qu'en plus justement avec cette question de l'antisémitisme qu'on ne peut pas éluder, c'est quand même dangereux je trouve de jeter l'opprobre sur tout ce qui de près ou de loin a un lien avec Israël ou aurait un lien avec Israël.
Déjà, rappelons quand même une évidence, c'est que les communautés juives qui vivent ici en Europe, qu'on le veuille ou non, ont pour la très grande majorité un lien avec Israël, c'est-à-dire dans leur famille, dans leur...
Enfin, voilà. Et c'est un fait. Donc à partir du moment où on dit tout ce qui a un lien avec Israël, on le rejette, forcément que la frontière avec l'antisémitisme, ça devient un petit peu compliqué,
puisque ça concerne alors une grande... alors, je ne vais pas dire toute la communauté juive, mais une très grande partie de la communauté juive ici.
Donc, c'est important d'en venir à la question de l'antisémitisme parce que autant effectivement, je pense qu'il faut faire attention à ne pas assimiler à de l'antisémitisme toute critique de la politique israélienne, bien évidemment. Sinon...
Ce qui était fait.
Ce qui malheureusement est même et de plus en plus le cas, je trouve. Mais d'un autre côté, force est de constater que la critique de la politique israélienne est le cache-sexe pour beaucoup d'un antisémitisme.
Ça, c'est très clair. Et là, je suis pas en train de parler des Arabes hein, pour être très claire. Je parle vraiment notamment des milieux de gauche ici en Europe...
La personnalité que tu évoquais tout à l'heure et qui n'aime pas beaucoup.
Par exemple, voilà, mais il a beaucoup d'émules quand même hein. C'est-à-dire qu'on a une logique de, alors souvent d'un antisémitisme inconscient.
Quand je dis inconscient, c'est un antisémitisme qui va pas vraiment se dire explicitement, qui va plutôt se transmettre par une lecture des choses.
L'idée par exemple que Israël ou les Juifs seraient en fait ceux qui manipulent tout le récit médiatique, qui est quand même un truc qu'on entend beaucoup.
Ben ça, c'est proprement antisémite hein. C'est l'imagerie antisémite des Juifs qui tirent les ficelles derrière ce qu'on entend.
Donc en fait, la frontière, elle est mince et on ne peut pas. Et c'est là que j'en veux un petit peu entre guillemets à ces étudiants, même si je comprends leur jeunesse et leur fougue hein, qu'on soit clair.
C'est bien dit ça. Je comprends leur jeunesse et leur ignorance.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais je trouve qu'on peut pas se permettre en fait d'être approximatif sur ces questions-là et on peut pas se permettre de...
On sait qu'il y a des problèmes d'antisémitisme autour de ce conflit, tout comme il y a des problèmes aussi, on pourrait dire, d'islamophobie, etc.
Mais enfin quand même particulièrement antisémitisme sur la question israélienne, sur la question du rapport à Israël. Et donc on ne peut pas se dédouaner de ça, se laver les mains et de dire : On s'en fout, tout ce qui est d'Israël, on boycotte.
Non, il y a un contexte particulier. Et moi, c'est un truc que je répète souvent, même aussi à mes étudiants et tout.
Le fait qu'il y ait eu un génocide, que ça nous plaise ou non, on peut pas dire : Oh non, ça, on met de côté. On peut pas mettre ça de côté.
En fait, le génocide juif, il est pas si ancien que ça. C'est comme ça. Ça peut nous emmerder, mais c'est la vérité.
Et c'est... Alors, on pourrait dire : Oui, mais c'est pas les Belges qui ont commis le génocide. C'est vrai. En même temps, on peut aussi dire qu'on a laissé faire.
C'est un « on » collectif hein, bien sûr.
Oui, on nous a pas trop laissé le choix d'empêcher, mais oui.
Ouais, mais enfin, il y aurait pu y avoir plus de résistance aussi, voilà. Donc... Et encore hein, on n'est pas la France encore une fois.
Nous, on n'a pas eu Vichy, on n'a pas eu le Vel d'Hiv, etc.
J'aime bien quand tu craches sur la France.
Non, non, mais...
Même en France, je crache sur la France. Je ne me gêne pas. Alors pas sur la France, mais sur... En tout cas cette histoire collaborationniste, je pense que c'est important à rappeler parce que ça montre aussi que... Comment dire
? Ouais, l'histoire, elle continue à façonner quand même notre rapport au monde quoi. Et je suis persuadée que,
voilà, ce fantôme-là de la collaboration française, par exemple, il se rejoue aussi dans le rapport à Israël-Palestine, c'est très clair.
Oui oui. Donc ça, c'est pour le fait qu'il faut faire très attention donc à,
voilà, cette différence assez imperceptible, comme tu le disais, entre un boycott total d'Israël et de tout ce qui est lié de près ou loin à Israël et l'antisémitisme.
Donc cette accusation d'antisémitisme qui, de l'autre côté, est revenue quand même assez régulièrement. Moi, je me souviens, je sais pas si tu te rappelles de ça, mais de Raja Marwan qui avait fait une story avec je ne sais plus quelle musique
et il y avait une association juive belge qui avait dit : Mais cette musique est liée à...
J'aurais dû faire des recherches, j'aurais dû reprendre l'information, mais elle est liée à un truc vaguement antisémite.
Ça me dit quelque chose, ouais.
Et donc Raja Marwan est antisémite. Et c'est une accusation qui revenait assez régulièrement, assez facilement.
C'était assez choquant parce que j'avais un peu l'impression qu'à force d'utiliser ce mot n'importe comment, finalement...
On banalise.
Voilà, ça cesse d'être quelque chose de choquant si on l'emploie tous les deux jours.
Alors là, je vais vraiment être dans du « et en même temps » à la Macron. C'est que je pense réellement que depuis le 7 octobre, il y a une résurgence de l'antisémitisme.
Ça, je suis persuadée. Et je parle d'une résurgence globale. Il y a eu d'ailleurs, de toute façon, ça, c'est...
Je veux dire, les chiffres le montrent hein. Il y a eu une explosion des actes antisémites à travers l'Europe, etc.
Donc je pense vraiment qu'on ne peut pas contourner ça. Et encore une fois, c'est trop facile de manière générale de dire : Oui, mais nous, on n'a rien à voir avec ça et tout.
Non. En fait, il y a un problème collectif parce qu'on a un passé collectif par rapport à cette question. Donc je pense vraiment que ça, c'est une réalité.
Malheureusement, et en même temps, justement, on a aussi... Alors il y a quelques années, j'aurais pas dit ça, mais maintenant, je le constate de plus en plus.
Il y a une instrumentalisation de l'antisémitisme pour...
De l'accusation d'antisémitisme, oui.
Oui oui, c'est ça. Donc... Ben du coup, c'est une instrumentalisation de l'antisémitisme pour moi. C'est-à-dire, c'est d'utiliser un fait extrêmement grave qu'est l'antisémitisme et qui est extrêmement présent.
J'ai beaucoup d'amis juifs qui me parlent de leur peur, de leur peur actuelle, vraiment même à vivre en société.
C'est pas normal du tout. Donc... Mais c'est d'utiliser ça pour, en fait, comme arme de discrédit en réalité, pour attaquer des opposants politiques.
Pour attaquer particulièrement la gauche, parce qu'on est, je le disais, dans une phase de diabolisation de la gauche et pour attaquer aussi les minorités.
Malheureusement, quelqu'un comme Raja Marwan, elle, elle est à la fois la gauche et les minorités. Donc ça, c'est...
évidemment, elle va être la cible de ce genre d'accusations et je trouve ça totalement injuste, que ce soit clair, par exemple, la concernant.
Mais ça nous oblige... En fait, c'est pour ça qu'on est toujours sur un fil. On doit être super attentif sur cette question.
On doit être hyper prudent, on doit être hyper attentif aussi à ce que nous disent la communauté juive, à leur peur, à leur insécurité, qui est pas seulement un sentiment, hein, qui est encore une fois, il y a eu des agressions antisémites, etc.
Donc c'est pas juste : « Oh, ça se passe dans leur tête ».
Non, je pense qu'il y a réellement une insécurité que vivent cette communauté, en plus depuis très longtemps, parce que rappelons qu'après les attentats et tout, la plupart des lieux juifs sont sous protection militaire, etc.
Enfin, je parle ici des synagogues, etc. Donc le sentiment d'insécurité, il est réel et il est pas... On a une responsabilité collective.
On peut pas juste dire : « Oui, mais ça, c'est juste les quelques antisémites extrémistes qui vont faire des choses pas bien, mais nous, on n'a rien à voir avec ça ».
Non, je pense qu'on peut tous contribuer à essayer de, ben essayer de faire baisser ce sentiment d'insécurité, tout simplement.
Et ça, je trouve que trop souvent, on est soit dans un camp, soit dans l'autre. Enfin, on en revient à ça. Soit on dit : « Tout le monde est antisémite », je caricature, ou soit on dit : « L'antisémitisme, non, c'est marginal, ça n'existe pas ».
Oui ou c'est fini, c'était avant.
C'était avant, c'est ça. Et donc y a du déni un peu de part et d'autre quoi. Et moi, ça m'inquiète beaucoup. Honnêtement, ça, c'est un aspect qui m'inquiète beaucoup parce que je vois beaucoup de...
Là, je parle vraiment de mes amis juifs. Je vois leur, en fait, leur détresse. Ils ont aussi l'impression de plus en plus de ne pas être compris par les autres citoyens, d'être justement juste diabolisés.
Ils ont l'impression aussi qu'ils peuvent plus dire que oui, ils sont attachés à Israël. Objectivement, oui, c'est vrai, parce qu'ils ont de la famille là-bas, parce qu'historiquement, Israël, ça représente quelque chose et tout.
Ils ont l'impression, mais si on dit ça maintenant, ben c'est comme si c'était la porte ouverte à toutes les insultes au nom de : « Ah, on n'est pas antisémite, on critique Israël ».
Donc on sent bien qu'il y a des glissements qui sont, ben qui sont délétères. Et ça se passe en même temps dans un contexte du débat public qui est pourri, où on diabolise la gauche, où on diabolise tout ce qui est vaguement musulman aussi.
Donc tout ça fait que, ben oui, c'est très compliqué d'avoir une parole, ce que je suis en train d'essayer d'avoir là pour le moment durant ce podcast, mais c'est très compliqué d'avoir une parole...
Oui, ça on sent très bien.
Fine, en quelque sorte, sur ces questions.
Voilà, mais donc ce que j'allais dire, c'est que c'est des enjeux qui sont très nuancés, avec des, oui, des nuances de gris.
C'est pas forcément l'antisémitisme, ça peut y ressembler, c'est pas... Enfin, voilà. Tout simplement, tu évoquais tes amis juifs.
Il y a simplement ce fait que ce n'est pas parce qu'on est lié à Israël qu'on est israélien, que forcément, on soutient...
Netanyahou.
Netanyahou, voilà. Qui est donc toujours actif dans un gouvernement en partie d'extrême droite. Donc oui, effectivement, plus on tend vers la simplification, vers le manichéisme, vers le,
la binarité, plus on s'enfuit, plus on s'éloigne de la nuance.
Et forcément, ça met en danger des personnes, voilà, concernées, des personnes juives, des personnes liées à Israël.
En fait, je pense que ça met à la fois en danger ici des minorités, très concrètement, et ça, en plus, ça ne participe pas à, ben résoudre le conflit israélo-palestinien.
Enfin, alors évidemment, on pourrait se dire : « De toute façon, on ne peut pas résoudre le conflit israélo-palestinien ».
Oui, mais enfin, là aussi, c'est une question collective en quelque sorte, ce conflit. C'est... Est-ce que le but est encore d'essayer de trouver une solution ?
Parce que c'est ça la perspective. Alors là, je peux citer une amie qui est Simone Susskind, que tu connais peut-être de nom, qui est une des rares, bon, elle est juive, bien sûr.
Enfin, je dis bien sûr parce que je pense que pas mal de gens la connaissent. Elle a dirigé le CCLJ, qui est une organisation juive ici à Bruxelles.
Et elle, c'est une des rares qui, je trouve, continue à essayer de parler de solution à ce conflit. C'est-à-dire à la fois qui parle d'antisémitisme, qui parle d'islamophobie et tout, donc qui parle de toute la question de l'ici,
mais aussi qui essaye d'œuvrer justement, notamment avec des universitaires.
On parlait tout à l'heure des universitaires à la fois palestiniens et israéliens. Elle continue à travailler avec des universitaires israéliens, palestiniens, etc.
pour dire : « Mais réfléchissons à comment on va pouvoir un jour s'en sortir ». Parce que ça doit quand même rester l'issue, j'espère, de se dire à un moment donné...
Alors bien sûr que nous, en tant que Belges, on peut rien y faire, mais je pense quand même qu'il y a un engagement collectif, ne fut-ce que pour essayer de mettre sur la table des propositions.
Et ça, quand je vois ce type d'initiative, et là, ça rejoint un petit peu ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur le fait que le boycott académique, je trouve pas que c'est vraiment très intelligent, c'est que c'est...
C'est jeune et fougueux, tu dis ça.
Oui, c'est jeune et fougueux et je l'ai été, hein, donc ça, je comprends. Non, non, y a un côté que je comprends et un autre côté où je me dis : « Mais en fait...
» En tout cas, particulièrement pour ce conflit qui est si enlisé, si long, si intriqué dans plein de problématiques, est-ce qu'à un moment donné, on va pouvoir se dire : « Ben y a rien à faire.
On va devoir se mettre autour de la table ». C'est un on très collectif ici, bien sûr, mais se mettre autour de la table pour trouver un arrangement, en fait.
T'sais, je veux dire, c'est pas un conflit qui va se terminer avec soit la victoire d'Israël, soit la victoire des Palestiniens.
Non, ouais.
C'est un conflit qui va se terminer si tout le monde accepte de trouver un arrangement. Et ça, je ne dis pas ça pour renvoyer
parfaitement dos à dos les deux camps, entre guillemets, parce que je pense quand même qu'il y a une situation d'occupation. Je pense que c'est quand même le pouvoir, il est du côté des Israéliens et il n'est pas du côté de l'autorité palestinienne.
C'est très clair. Je pense qu'il y a vraiment une situation d'injustice extrêmement forte dans les territoires palestiniens.
J'y suis allée plusieurs fois, je suis très sensible à ça. Donc je ne suis pas non plus à renvoyer tout le monde aux ados, mais je pense que dans ce conflit particulièrement, il n'y aura pas un gagnant et un perdant.
Il y aura à un moment donné une nécessité de trouver une conciliation. Et donc je me demande si nous qui sommes en Belgique, en France et tout, avec tous nos affects, notre rôle, c'est pas d'essayer de pousser dans ce sens-là.
J'ai un peu cette impression-là, parce que si c'est utiliser ce qui se passe en Israël-Palestine pour, en gros, exacerber les tensions ici, bon, c'est quand même pas hyper...
Enfin voilà, ça va pas tellement nous aider.
Par contre, utiliser notre engagement, notre expertise, que sais-je, ou nos convictions pour essayer de pousser une solution dans cette région du monde et pas seulement là-bas d'ailleurs, en Syrie, etc.
De voir comment, en tant que démocrate, on peut soutenir les processus démocratiques là-bas. Je trouve que ça, c'est l'angle mort quoi.
Il y a trop peu de gens qui s'engagent vraiment à ça. Parfois, j'ai l'impression même que le fait que ces conflits s'enlisent, ça arrange une certaine partie de la population parce qu'ils peuvent continuer à
taper sur leur récit quoi, justement.
Oui, oui. On s'approche doucement de la fin de cet entretien. Il y a plein de sujets que j'aurais aimé explorer avec toi.
On aurait pu parler effectivement des soutiens, des positions, du mouvement réformateur, des Colos, etc. en Belgique. Je vais plutôt me diriger vers la question, donc pour revenir sur l'évolution de l'antisémitisme cette dernière année.
Est-ce que tu as pu observer, toi qui observes l'ultra-droite, l'extrême droite, dans les mouvements fascistes, est-ce que tu as pu observer une évolution, une récupération, vis-à-vis de ces événements ?
Très clairement. Alors, pour le dire très brièvement, l'extrême droite, elle est antisémite, profondément, culturellement, historiquement, donc elle va toujours rester antisémite.
Mais par ailleurs, elle a compris que, en quelque sorte, le soutien à Israël, en tout cas une partie de l'extrême droite, que le soutien à Israël lui permettait de taper sur les musulmans et les Arabes.
Et donc, comme elle est à la fois antisémite et islamophobe, voilà, elle est dans un truc un peu cornélien. Alors, on rigole, mais c'est vraiment ça, en fait.
Mais c'est un gouvernement d'extrême droite, donc ça va.
Ça va, c'est ça. Il y a quelque chose qui compense. Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que là, il y a quelque chose de
d'assez tragique puisqu'on a une partie de l'extrême droite européenne qui est en train de se présenter comme pro-israélienne
et donc, en fait, qui se dédouane de son antisémitisme, qui est évidemment toujours là, et de son histoire et de son rapport au négationnisme, etc.
Et malheureusement, une partie de la communauté juive se laisse tenter par ce narratif-là.
Pas évidemment, pas toute la communauté juive, hein, mais ça veut dire qu'on a, à l'image de la société, hein, on peut avoir une partie de la communauté juive qui va être
tentée par le soutien à l'extrême droite, pensant que l'extrême droite va les protéger.
Alors qu'en réalité, certes, l'extrême droite voue une haine aux Arabes et aux musulmans et aux Noirs, etc. Mais elle voue la même haine aux Juifs.
Donc on a ce positionnement qui est assez malsain. De toute façon, tout positionnement d'extrême droite est malsain, bien évidemment, mais qui est actuellement, de la part des extrêmes droites européennes, globalement, hein, de feindre...
Enfin, ils ne se positionnent pas tous exactement de la même manière, mais de feindre en tout cas un soutien au gouvernement Netanyahou.
Alors sans doute que c'est en partie vrai parce qu'effectivement, Netanyahou est en extrême droite. Il y a un peu une grande solidarité des extrêmes droites à l'international.
Mais il y a cette espèce d'hypocrisie où, en quelque sorte, elle se wash, elle se lave de son antisémitisme, et elle vend sa haine des Arabes et des musulmans.
Ça lui permet de dire que nous nous sommes réinventés puisque nous sommes du côté des Juifs.
Bien sûr, c'est ce que quelqu'un comme Marine Le Pen, par exemple, fait de manière très explicite dans son discours. Elle dit : « Ça montre bien que l'antisémitisme maintenant est derrière nous.
» Donc... Mais ça, c'est très dangereux. Bien évidemment, parce que ça déguise l'antisémitisme sous des formes contemporaines qui le rendent moins perceptible, mais non moins plus dangereux.
Il faut rappeler que l'antisémitisme, c'est vraiment la haine,
la haine matrice de nos sociétés, hein. Moi, je le rappelle toujours dans mes conférences, c'est-à-dire que c'est un peu le modèle de toutes les haines de nos sociétés, historiquement.
Et donc on va pas s'en débarrasser comme ça et certainement pas l'extrême droite.
Oui, oui. Donc là, on parle de l'extrême droite au niveau européen, au niveau des partis. Si on regarde un petit peu, un niveau un petit peu plus underground, des amis, Soral, Vincent Lapierre et compagnie.
Malheureusement, pas si underground d'ailleurs, parce qu'ils ont quand même du succès dans ce sens-là, oui.
Est-ce que à ce niveau-là, pas forcément ces personnalités en particulier, est-ce que là, tu as pu observer des mouvements ?
J'ai pas tellement suivi. Alors, j'ai beaucoup suivi les mouvances soraliennes il y a quelques années. Je les suis moins maintenant, mais-
Je suis soulagé.
Oui, il y a une époque où je regardais toutes les vidéos de Soral. Oh là là, c'était terrible. Évidemment, pour pouvoir les analyser, mais c'était assez violent, notamment en matière de négationnisme, hein.
Soral est très violent là-dessus.
Et lui, pour le coup, il va plutôt essayer de récupérer les musulmans.
C'est ça que j'allais dire.
On aime bien les musulmans, soyez avec nous, aucun problème avec les musulmans.
C'est ça.
Pourquoi ? On devine pourquoi.
Oui, oui, c'est exactement. Lui, il va faire semblant. Et ça fait déjà une quinzaine d'années d'ailleurs, hein, qu'il est sur cette ligne,
où il fait semblant d'être celui qui va défendre les banlieues, etc.
contre justement la menace juive, enfin les sionistes, etc., etc. Donc lui, avec-
Qui agit dans l'ombre.
Bien sûr. Donc, c'est pour ça que je disais tout à l'heure que quand on disait l'extrême droite, c'est en fait une partie de l'extrême droite européenne qui a un soutien du gouvernement israélien.
On a cette extrême droite qui se présente comme antisioniste, qui est en fait extrêmement antisémite, bien évidemment, qui continue à avoir du succès notamment sur les réseaux conspirationnistes sur Internet, hein.
C'est-à-dire qui utilise tout ce registre conspirationniste du grand complot sioniste, etc. pour, ben, pour nourrir la haine d'Israël.
C'est évidemment tout aussi dangereux que le soutien inconditionnel au gouvernement israélien, puisque ça va de pair avec une haine très décomplexée des Juifs.
Et là aussi, prétexter qu'ils défendent les Palestiniens n'est qu'un cache-sexe, hein. Quand quelqu'un comme Dieudonné, par exemple-
Dit qu'il défend les Palestiniens, c'est évidemment-- ou Soral, c'est évidemment juste pour taper sur les Juifs et les soi-disant sionistes.
Je dis toujours soi-disant parce que dans leur langage à eux, sioniste égal Juif tout simplement.
Bien, comme je disais, on s'approche vraiment, vraiment de la fin. Mais donc pour revenir sur les issues éventuelles, ce vers quoi on pourrait se diriger tout doucement, idéalement dans un monde utopique, en Israël.
Déjà, est-ce que tu es d'accord pour qualifier la situation en Israël et en Palestine comme étant une situation d'apartheid ?
Alors, c'est toujours-- c'est comme le mot génocide, c'est comme le mot apartheid, machin et tout. C'est toujours délicat, hein, parce que moi, je suis quelqu'un qui suis toujours extrêmement précautionneuse avec les termes.
Je me suis fait une fois incendier sur les réseaux sociaux parce que j'avais dit par exemple que je n'étais pas pour le fait qu'on dise qu'il y avait un génocide en Palestine.
Et donc la question de l'apartheid est pour moi aussi une question sensible, parce que quand on fait ça, on s'approprie en fait une autre histoire.
L'apartheid, on sait que c'est lié à l'histoire de l'Afrique du Sud, etc. Et je trouve que c'est toujours-
Tu voudrais inventer un-
Délicat de faire des transpositions.
Tu voudrais inventer un néologisme alors ?
Dans l'absolu, oui, j'aimerais mieux. Mais cela étant dit, je veux pas non plus ergoter. Je disais tout à l'heure : j'aime pas quand on ergote sur le mot terrorisme, donc je veux pas reproduire la même logique.
Donc ça me choque pas. Ça me choque pas que certains le fassent et je comprends pourquoi ils le font. Mais-
Pour être clair-
Mais moi, je vais pas l'utiliser.
Voilà, OK. Corrige-moi si je me trompe, mais on est dans une situation où les résidents, les citoyens, j'allais dire les citoyens palestiniens, mais du coup, bon, comme ils sont pas reconnus, mais soit.
Les Palestiniens ont des plaques d'immatriculation différentes et n'ont pas accès à des zones-
Bien sûr.
Auxquelles les Israéliens ont accès. Donc, on est vraiment, quand on regarde ça, ça nous rappelle le logiciel de l'Afrique du Sud.
Donc c'est pour ça que le mot-
C'est pour ça que j'ai dit que je comprends qu'on l'utilise. D'autant que pour être allée plusieurs fois là-bas, les injustices à l'égard des Palestiniens, elles sont vraiment actées, elles sont scandaleuses.
Le fait, par exemple, moi, une des choses qui m'a le plus choquée là-bas, c'est-- c'est pas seulement le mur, même si le mur est très choquant, mais c'est la non-liberté de circulation des Palestiniens.
Voilà, oui.
Ça, c'est des Palestiniens qui vivent à sept kilomètres de Jérusalem et qui peuvent pas y aller. Ça, je trouve que ça nourrit une injustice qui est vraiment inacceptable.
Donc dans ce sens-là, je comprends qu'on dise apartheid.
Cette situation-là, est-ce que c'est simplement le fruit-- voilà, on disait tous les Israéliens ne soutiennent pas forcément Netanyahou.
Est-ce que c'est, voilà, le fruit d'une politique d'extrême droite de Netanyahou ? Ou bien est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus soutenu par la population directement ?
Et en fait, il faudrait que ça reste comme ça, d'après vous.
Alors, il faudrait évidemment faire un sondage machin et tout, hein, mais globalement, je pense que là, ça dépasse la question de l'extrême droite pour le coup, puisque ça a été
une politique progressive en Israël de toujours mettre plus à distance les Palestiniens, de les rendre toujours plus invisibles.
Et c'est terrible parce que c'est une manière justement de laisser les gens croire que les Palestiniens sont des êtres dangereux qu'il faut tenir à distance.
Et je pense malheureusement qu'une-- alors, je peux pas dire une grande partie, mais oui, une bonne partie des Israéliens a véritablement cette
cette croyance qu'un Palestinien est dangereux et que donc il faut le tenir à l'écart et que donc les discriminations à l'égard des Palestiniens sont en quelque sorte justifiées par leur besoin de sécurité.
Et je pense qu'ils le pensent sincèrement.
C'est récursif finalement, puisqu'on ne pense pas forcément, enfin, ils ne pensent pas forcément que les Palestiniens sont dangereux par essence,
mais peut-être plus en raison du contexte, en raison du contexte de guerre qui fait que c'est compliqué de se parler, d'être au même endroit.
On ne sait pas ce qui va se passer. Et du coup, oui, c'est récursif, c'est infernal quoi.
C'est infernal parce qu'en plus, même au niveau de l'aménagement de l'espace et de la géographie, on pourrait dire, ça rend de plus en plus les deux peuples invisibles l'un pour l'autre.
Et donc ils ne se connaissent plus, ils ne se rencontrent plus.
Et pour éviter la colonisation, il faut des contacts interculturels, il faut du dialogue. Sinon, ça ne marche pas. Voilà, mais donc pour revenir à ma question, est-ce que,
est-ce que du coup, puisqu'on disait c'est soutenu largement par les Israéliens, est-ce que à ce niveau-là, on pourrait imaginer dans le futur des améliorations ou bien est-ce que
vraiment, on regarde la situation, on ne voit pas comment cet aspect-là pourrait changer ?
Bah,
c'est pour ça que je
citais tout à l'heure Simone Suskind parce que je la trouve extrêmement courageuse de continuer à essayer de se dire comment on pourrait faire pour que les gens se rencontrent et pour que les choses évoluent.
Moi, globalement, si je veux dire vraiment à titre personnel, je ne vois pas à l'heure actuelle comment ça peut bouger. Parce que justement, la situation s'est tellement empirée à ce niveau-là.
La colonisation continue, sans compter les crimes qui sont commis actuellement à Gaza. Je--
en fait, tant qu'il n'y a pas de volonté politique, c'est ça en fait,
de volonté politique que les choses changent, elles ne vont pas s'arranger dans la mesure où la société israélienne s'est enfermée justement dans l'idée que sa survie passait par la mise à distance des Palestiniens.
Je vais pas dire par l'enfermement, mais quand même, par le fait de contenir les Palestiniens.
Pour certains, je sais que tu n'aimes pas ce mot, mais pour certains, la solution, c'est le génocide.
Oui, bien sûr. Pour certains, la solution, c'est le génocide. Ça, je peux le dire tout à fait. Ce que je ne veux pas dire, c'est que pour le moment, il y a un génocide.
Ça, je trouve que c'est un peu plus délicat à dire. Mais qu'il y ait une volonté génocidaire de certains, bien évidemment.
Ça, c'est très clair. Veulent-- toute une partie des, de
plutôt des extrémistes israéliens, bien sûr, mais une partie des Israéliens veut que les Palestiniens disparaissent, voit les Palestiniens uniquement sous le prisme d'un problème à régler.
Et ça, bien évidemment que c'est la voie à une logique génocidaire. Ça, je l'annule pas du tout, hein, par contre, la logique.
Ce que je n'aime pas, c'est quand on dit : actuellement, il y a un génocide. Moi-même, pour la Syrie, où il y avait quand même un nombre de morts bien plus élevé, je n'ai jamais employé le terme génocide parce que je trouve que
il est chargé historiquement et qu'il faut faire très attention.
C'est peut-être facile de l'utiliser a posteriori.
Exactement, c'est ce que je dis toujours. En fait, pour moi, on donne le mot génocide après, quand on examine les faits. Par contre, de dénoncer une logique génocidaire ou une politique génocidaire, ça, je suis totalement d'accord.
Oui. Et donc
qu'est-ce que la communauté internationale peut faire, puisqu'il y a eu de fait un mandat d'arrêt émis par la Cour pénale internationale à l'encontre donc à la fois des leaders du Hamas mais aussi de Benyamin Netanyahou.
Et il y avait, je crois, donc une initiative au niveau des Nations unies pour justement qualifier, expliquer qu'il y avait un risque.
Ils n'ont pas dit une situation, un constat de génocide, mais un risque sérieux de génocide. Donc dans ce contexte-là, est-ce que en fait la communauté internationale a le moindre poids pour empêcher cela ?
Sachant que les armes viennent principalement des États-Unis.
Mais elle n'a pas de poids. Elle n'a aucun poids parce qu'elle n'a aucune volonté de faire cesser les violences.
Et là, moi, je m'attache vraiment à rappeler le précédent de la Syrie. Parce que j'entends beaucoup de gens qui disent : « Oh là là, c'est inédit que la communauté internationale ne fasse rien » et tout.
C'est pas du tout inédit, hein. On vient de laisser crever six cent mille Syriens juste dans un pays frontalier à Israël.
C'est-à-dire à partir du moment où, dans la région, on a laissé des bombardements se faire depuis des années et des années par des dictatures notamment, qu'on ne s'est pas engagé pour la protection des citoyens.
Parce que pour moi, c'est ça la communauté internationale, elle est normalement responsable de la protection des civils.
Il y a eu aucun engagement pour la protection des civils ces vingt dernières années dans la région, soyons clairs. Donc je ne pense pas du tout qu'il y ait en fait une volonté de la communauté internationale de protéger les civils. Et donc je-
La Belgique fait partie des rares pays avec l'Espagne à dénoncer la situation.
Oui.
Mais c'est soft quoi.
Mais c'est symbolique.
Oui.
Et c'est déjà bien. Je trouve ça déjà bien. Mais-
On ne peut pas faire plus en fait.
Mais s'il y avait vraiment-- mais ça n'arrivera jamais encore une fois, hein, je suis réaliste. Après la Syrie, je suis devenue très réaliste.
Mais s'il y avait vraiment une vraie volonté, on pourrait imaginer des moyens plus coercitifs. Parce qu'à un moment donné, il ne faut pas non plus être béni oui-oui, hein.
Comme on arrête une guerre, c'est avec des moyens militaires, bien évidemment.
Oui oui, ça, ça serait oui-
Ah mais oui, non, mais c'est sûr.
Déjà pour l'Ukraine, on le fait pas vraiment donc...
Mais déjà pour l'Ukraine, on le fait pas vraiment, soyons bien clairs. Mais pourtant, là aussi, hein, je sais que c'est pas un avis partagé par tout le monde, mais tu ne vas pas avec une colombe devant des chars.
À un moment donné, là, je parle au niveau global, hein. Si tu veux faire une pression sur un État quel qu'il soit, je pense par exemple à Bachar al-Assad
pour qu'il arrête de bombarder les gens, bah il faut montrer un peu tes moyens militaires, bien évidemment.
Et donc si on refuse, c'est aussi tout le leurre pour moi, hein, de l'idée : il faut discuter, il faut dissuader.
Oui, il faut discuter, il faut dissuader, mais à un moment donné, il faut aussi y-
Mettre la pression.
Y mettre la pression. C'est ça. En fait, je suis pas en train de dire qu'il faut bombarder Israël, qu'on soit bien clair, hein.
Mais une pression militaire d'une manière ou d'une autre. Une pression militaire, ça peut être on ne vous livre plus d'armes.
C'est aussi une pression militaire.
Ouais ouais.
Mais donc il faut une volonté et je ne pense pas que la volonté de mettre fin à ce conflit soit là. Je pense que c'est le problème central.
Une volonté de la communauté internationale, je veux dire.
Marie, merci beaucoup.
Merci à toi.
À la base, je pensais qu'on allait surtout parler de la couverture médiatique, mais ça s'est transformé en, voilà, en lecture politique internationale, mais c'est très naturel hein.
Je pense qu'il y a, c'est un, comme on le disait, un sujet, un conflit plein de nuances et plein de complexité.
Ouais.
Donc vraiment merci pour ces plus de septante minutes passées avec moi pour discuter de ce sujet. On se retrouve dans quatre ans pour parler de...
De la victoire de MeToo.
Oui voilà. Quand ce sera derrière nous.
C'est ça.
Super. Merci beaucoup Marie.
Merci.
À très bientôt.
À bientôt.
Voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cet entretien avec Marie Peltier. On a pu, vous l'avez entendu, aborder en profondeur les enjeux médiatiques du conflit et même la nature du conflit.
On a pu entendre les opinions de Marie et les miennes. J'espère que cette discussion vous a apporté un éclairage nouveau, que vous allez pouvoir aborder ce conflit
peut-être au travers d'une nouvelle perspective, de manière critique, que vous n'aviez peut-être pas avant.
Dans tous les cas, je ne doute pas que peut-être certaines personnes parmi vous ont été agacées par des propos qu'ils ont pu entendre.
J'espère que ce n'est pas le cas, mais je me doute que vu la nature du sujet, c'est sans doute le cas. Si c'est votre cas, s'il vous plaît, n'embêtez pas Marie.
S'il vous plaît, n'embêtez pas Marie. Il y a mon adresse e-mail, l'adresse e-mail de Septante Minutes Avec dans la description.
Soyez libres de m'écrire si vous avez des frustrations par rapport à la couverture médiatique qu'on a pu vous livrer aujourd'hui.
N'hésitez pas à partager l'épisode s'il vous a plu, au contraire. N'hésitez pas à vous abonner sur toutes les plateformes de podcast ou sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée pour ne pas manquer nos prochaines discussions.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt pour un nouvel épisode.